I read the script and I just got scared
I was like oh I gotta gotta do better i
got i gotta run up my game cuz shane is
really bringing it okay hey youtubers
it's Charlie so just Whedon has been
talking about Avengers 2 a lot lately so
I thought I'd do have video summarizing
all the best bits along with some cool
behind-the-scenes info most of what we'd
intent oo 'king about has been
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch in their
role in his Avengers movie but since
Bryan Singer cast Evan Peters is his
Quicksilver and days of future past it
seems like all anyone can ever talk
about is actually that Quicksilver
conundrum that is how these two movies
going to deal with using the same
characters mostly Whedon just says that
he's going to be doing his own thing
with his movie and just let Bryan Singer
do his own thing which i think is good
what's really interesting though is that
he said that Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch are going to be really important
to his story and Avengers 2 previously
we just kind of thought they were going
to be extras but it looks like now
they're going to be main cast members
and obviously since this is the first
time that we've met them in this Marvel
Universe it's going to be a bit of a
meet-cute situation between The Avengers
and Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
Avengers that's what we call ourselves
sort of like a team Earth's Mightiest
Heroes time thing that is the Avengers
characters with the exception of maybe
Nick Fury and the shield agents won't
have any idea who they are if you're not
really familiar with the comic book
history of these characters they were a
part of the Avengers during the 1960's
so that was a long time ago but I do
think that joss whedon is going to try
to pay some homage to some of those
scenes although his story will probably
be mostly original with maybe a few
elements from the comic books what I do
think is going to happen though is that
these characters will join The Avengers
at some point during the movie maybe not
permanently but in some official way
since their origin story with the
Avengers actually has a lot to do with
them leaving their father magneto I
don't think that they'll be doing the
original version of how they join The
Avengers just because of the legal
rights ramifications between Fox and
marvelled Disney it gets really
complicated so I won't explain it too
much in this video but let's just say
it's a bit timey wimey so now that we
know that there's such a big part of the
story what is it that they're going to
do that's going to help the Avengers
defeat Thanos well think about their
powers so
Scarlet Witch has this chaos magic or if
you like to think about it as her
controlling the laws of probability in
The Ultimates version of her character
she uses really complex math as a part
of her powers I think they might use a
version of that I don't think they're
going to get to magical with their
powers just because they haven't done
dr. strange yet and thora kind of took
magic and brought it into this practical
realm by explaining it as science I also
don't think we're going to see the
vision in this movie just because that's
a whole other character and while Joss
Whedon has said that there is one more
female character this is going to be a
superhero he hasn't announced her yet
although we will probably find out
sometime this fall just because they're
going to be shooting by that time so
let's talk about what else we do know is
going to be in the movie well since
Thanos is going to be in the movie and
the Infinity Gauntlet was teased in the
Thor movie obviously it's going to play
a role in Avengers 2 it might not be the
central part of the plot but obviously
if a character has super speed and a
character has the ability to control the
loss of probability those two characters
are probably going to help steal that
glove back from fan owes but maybe he
steals it at some point during the movie
or before the movie and the Avengers has
to get it back before he can change
reality in order for that theory to work
though fanis would have to have the
glove and he would have to be too
powerful for the Avengers to defeat him
without altering reality but hey if you
could alter reality or you had a
character that could do that why
wouldn't you use that power would it
just look amazing but let me know what
you think right below in the comments
how r Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
going to help the Avengers defeat Thanos
or solve the main problem of this movie
whatever it's going to be either way I
think they're going to be some really
funny moments to remember Joss Whedon
does comedy really well
let me know how you think that joss
whedon is going to use chaos magic and
super speed for comedy the wall joss
whedon is going to comic-con he's mostly
just going to do agents of shield stuff
so there's not going to be a lot of New
Avengers 2 information Marvel is doing a
panel and I will do a video for it be
sure to subscribe to get it i'll be
posting a preview for that panel
sometime this weekend they're mostly
going to be covering thor the dark world
and captain america 2 they might also
teased some more information about
guardians of the galaxy or maybe even
the Doctor Strange movie or ant-man or
some phase three movies but I wouldn't
count on it I would but the biggest
thing that we're gonna see is probably
some actual footage from Captain America
2 like i said i'm going to be posting a
lot of my comic con previews starting
this weekend just because it's the
fourth of july and i'll have a couple
extra days off so get excited in the
meantime i just did another big update
for legend of korra book 2 you can click
here to watch that or you can click here
to learn more about some of the videos
I'm going to do for comic-con thank you
so much for watching you guys are
amazing I thought
you